parce que c'est pour ça qu'il faut le
dire c'est ce qu'ils ont une perte
d'exploitation oui dans leur contrat
mobilise et vous allez voir des conseils
et surtout ne laissez vous pas entendre
que vous n'êtes pas assuré parce que moi
la première chose qu'on m'a dit mais
vous êtes passion oui et je suis même
pas d'accord parce que là vous dites
c'est vrai vous dites dans votre contrat
vous avez la chance d'avoir un contrat
béton mais nombre de restaurateurs
assuré lois sont rabattues vous aurez on
les laisse crever et ils vont quand on
va réouvrir les résidents et familles et
en dénonçant des choses qu'on avait très
bien sûr et on va rouvrir un restaurant
le mec il a 80 millions de dettes on va
lui dire facture aura 80 euros de dettes
mais peuvent payer quand même la
fermeture des restaurants pour vous
c'est une catastrophe pour vous c'est
une catastrophe pour tout le monde fait
dans tous les commerces fermés c'est une
catastrophe je suis pas le seul bon j'ai
la chance d'être là ce soir mais il ya
des gens qui peuvent pas parler qui
savent d'instinct situation extrêmement
compliquée si vous êtes d'accord avec la
décision du gouvernement ou de je peux
pas rentrer dans cette polémique là moi
je suspens je suis pas spécialiste
ce que je sais faire c'est sait faire le
métier de restaurateur savoir s'il faut
ré ouvrir aux pas réouvrir
il ya des gens qui sont concernés je
rentrais pas dans cette polémique mais
si on nous ferme si on y est national is
no fermeture il faut qu'on nationalise
nos pertes
on peut pas nous laisser assumer à nous
les pertes parce que ce soit à travers
l'état qui doit aller jusqu'au bout des
aides
parce que ils ont fait une partie du
chemin mais doivent aller jusqu'au bout
je dis pas de gains jeudi de pertes
oui il faut pas fou pack penser qu'on va
gagner de l'argent noir cet argent il
est là c'est parce qu'il rentre juste
pour ressortir mais pour l'instant ils
rentrent pas suffisamment il ya un
ressort beaucoup à l'image de dire aux
assureurs maintenant prenez vous aussi
les responsables c'est des trucs cotée
en bourse et assurance on sait très bien
qu'ils feront rien et ils font du
chantage à l'assurance et à l'état de m
on